wer weiß welches essen am besten in
restaurants ist natürlich die kellner
und dementsprechend werden wir heute
einen tag lang nur die empfehlungen von
kellner und kellnerinnen bestellen ohne
zu wissen was wir bekommen die video
dekan tatsächlich von euch aus dem video
einen tag nur das teuerste essen
bestellen haben welche von euch
geschrieben max macht das ganze doch mal
mit empfehlungen von kennern und das
machen wir heute kurz gesagt ich würde
sagen wir vorher einfach an ich hab
hunger es geht frühstücken und da bin
ich besonders gespannt weil da kann
wirklich alles passieren bei dem café wo
wir hingehen so erster stopp café buer
das bekannteste frühstück so kahl in
köln jeder kennt glaube ich so diese
pancakes mit vanilla ice anteile alles
schön und gut aber wir gucken heute was
der geheimtipp ist soll ich auch getränk
machen getränken speisen was ihr wollt
aber was ich weiß noch gar nicht so
richtig das gleiche sagen sollte das ist
einfach so ein zufälliges gericht dann
wird die tages empfehlung aber ich hoffe
die lassen sich etwas gutes einfallen
aber zuversicht weil hier ist eigentlich
immer lecker ok also das ding ist ich
will einfach nur das haben was du
empfiehlt also deine empfehlung ich will
nicht wissen was es ist wird es kalt ist
haben das café mäßig oder was ich mag
alles also du darfst machen was immer du
willst es auch deine empfehlung als
geschenk eine empfehlung als gericht und
ich lasse mich überraschen
was haben wir hier
heißt banana so ja auch ich bin sehr
gespannt dankeschön dankeschön
ja ich habe den ice banana soja latte
ich glaube wenn man im café auf dem land
geht sagt ich hätte gern ein
direkt raus geworden ok dann probiere
ich meine banane muss ich ehrlich sagen
würde ich mir sonst nicht bestellt oh
mein gott du nochmal also ich es nicht
gern bananen so wegen der konsistenz und
so aber ich mag bananen milchshakes und
das schmeckt wirklich wie so ein geiler
cremig aber nicht übel
sonntag entschied sich das ist ist das
okay
das ist gerade zehn von zehn einfach
braig für stars der gala da drüben so
pickel tonnen zwar auch noch ein
bisschen bisschen limette wirklich also
ich wusste nicht dass es viele gibt wenn
es wüsste dann hätte ich das auch
bestellt
[Musik]
unten
da geht so viele akteure der käse von
den mac entschließt so richtig schön
bringt das pult ist wirklich spicy die
champignons kommen auch was
das blieb ist so geil mariniert muss
aber darauf kommt das ist normal sagt
also das ist und nochmals dank könnte
mein favourit gericht hier seien in
diesem café es ist unnormal egger
diese cremigkeit von den mccanns schießt
die wirklichkeiten impuls liefers
richtig richtig definiert ist dazu aber
auch so dieses oft mit champignons
frühstück ein fetter beute wenn es so
weiter geht dann wird das ein sehr
kranker tag 12 90 74 weniger als gedacht
habe top war richtig geil und ich bin
mega gespannt was uns jetzt noch für
überraschungen erwarten jetzt wird es
ein bisschen schicker wir gehen dann ein
restaurant und das halte ich aus kann
auch teurer werden je nachdem was sie
mir bringen wollen schauen wir mal so
laut ich habe gemerkt ich habe keinen
namen gedroppt wir hatten uns letztens
auch schon mal manchmal ist wollen ihre
straße einfach nicht namentlich genannt
werden aber das hat noch niemand gesagt
dass sie nicht wollen dass mein film
deshalb alles gute ich bin sehr gespannt
wie gesagt das ist ein bisschen mehr
restaurant- und dementsprechend kann uns
das wildeste erwarten hier heute aber
ich will die karte gar nicht einmal so
ich glaube am nachbartisch plattform
karten gebracht wir nehmen gar keine
karte wir waren auch so können wir eine
sache machen du musst hier gar keine
karte geben ich werde einfach nur von
dir ein getränk und ein gericht was du
empfängst und ich will gar nicht wissen
was das ist normal das kann man einfach
der manager inhaber chef wie auch immer
und hat selbst einmal so trainerfrage
stellt unverträglichkeiten so ich glaube
der macht uns das gut ist fertig bin
gespannt
sie ja ganz franken was ist das für ein
verhalten wie das ist so eine mischung
aus einem green new deal gin tonic und
namens limo und es ist das mega
erfrischend und mega lag sehr sehr gut
[Musik]
getrübt wird das kartoffelpüree
thunfischsteaks mit sesam große sojasoße
ingwer gegrilltes gemüse und dazu dieser
wilde cocktail
[Musik]
die erste dame schon genommen mamma mia
der ist wirklich butterweich der
fischkutter super sie
überhaupt erstmal das getröte kartoffel
drehen mit seinem frisierten möhren chip
des profils im sinne interessiert
richtig lecker war ja auch so schön
farben ohne sehr schönes plating
wirklich sehr hübsch was soll ich sagen
das gedrückte kartoffel ist über skype
macht ja auch häufiger machst du nicht
einfach lecker das haben wir hier feines
kürbis das ist dann auch so eine
wichtige aufgabe für die kellner oder
restaurantbetreiber nimmt man
mal gucken wollen sich ihrem lob ab
welches gut machen und die können sich
ihr lob abholen
gut wenn du was von dir hält dann liebst
du auch diese challenge mit so können
sie wirklich mal zeigen musst du kannst
kommt keiner sagt er hat ja auch
schnitzel so oder so ich nehme das aber
ohne dass und ohne dass und ohne das was
ich finde auch sehr sehr geil dass man
auch auf einem teller getrüffeltem
kartoffelpüree und so diesem so schön
war es ist auch einfach mutig so ohne
regeln aber er macht seinen job
natürlich super du ist das dann kannst
du wieder komplett neue schmecken
glücklicher marks
entscheidung des herz- oder haben wir
also war ja nicht unsere aber sehr gut
also das war mega lecker drink und essen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das
abendessen noch mal so gut wird aber ich
hoffe es und wir haben es auch da was
besonders rausgesucht weitergehen sonst
wären die note zu geben das frühstück
zehn von zehn gesagt ja ich kann doch
ich wills ich will nicht so sein aber
ist es auch zehn von zehn gibt es ist so
die empfehlung schmecken wirklich es für
zeiten unser abendessen wir gehen zudem
erkennen vielleicht viele von euch von
nike und ich bin gespannt was die ganz
schönes anbieten hier sitzen ich bin
gespannt was es wird auf jeden fall
asiatischen küche gibt es hier aber es
gibt sehr sehr viele kreationen
dementsprechend kann es nur besser
werden es gibt ja das gibt nudeln es
gibt ab es gibt glaube ich cocktails
auch retten
aber ich bin gespannt also ich mache ein
youtube video und eingesprochen gar
keine karte weil ich würde einfach
komplett auf seine empfehlung vertrauen
für getränke und essen ich will nicht
wie ich es vertrag alles ist er ist
alles ich trinke als wissen einfach
worauf du lust hast du wo du sagst dass
das beste und ich hasse zu überraschen
bestellen was mir auch was zu trinken
danke jetzt ihre tv wird er aber diesmal
ist ja auch ein bisschen komisch ich
will
ja also ich muss sagen dadurch dass er
so tonic water dann ist das so eine
bittere note ab sehr sehr geil es war
auf jeden fall was anderes also nicht
das was man erwartet wenn man limonade
bekommt aber ich find's ok ich hab
gerade schon gedacht vielleicht kommen
auch ein paar unterschiedliche sachen
etwas haben wir hier harry ahnt es war
ok ok schicken pops geil sie rahmen ok
danke dir wow die habe ich schon
gegessen die chicken märkte zu
gerichtsprozessen kritiken papst habe
ich tatsächlich schon mal gegessen den
rest kann ich gar nicht was ich halt
jetzt schon mal direkt sagen muss dass
sie tanz ultra deswegen
letztere mit
[Musik]
und probieren ich glaube es noch sehr
heiß
ich kann es gar nicht einordnen das ist
so spies käsespätzle rahmen nudeln und
noch so irgendwas krank ist es sogar
noch dabei gehört das sind diese
frühlingszwiebeln ihr so eingeschnitten
sind geeignet ist auch dabei beim sehr
lecker und so ein bisschen
parallelisierte meist
irgendwie so würzig dadurch dass da so
angeordnet
aber ich glaube ich mache ein paar sie
zu allem deshalb muss ich jetzt leider
weiter testen wir nehmen uns hier einmal
so einen schicken pop
richtig gut aussah braucht richtig mit
sesam obendrauf im ganzen kompetenzen
[Musik]
hat dicke panade
jetzt kommt das nämlich auch noch umso
krasser weise so viel abgeht so diese
leicht im bitterkalten das noch ein
bisschen runter und wieder als sehr gut
passt sehr gut zusammen finde ich
absolut ist das teriyaki trockene
materie sehr gespannt
naja wirklich alles ist so eine textur
vom geschmack das ist gar nicht so toll
collect obu haft wird also wie ich
erwartet hatte ist schon fast
erschöpft aber der torf oder leute dass
es so eine reise von kuba schicken pops
zu rammen ich muss das glaube ich erst
mal bisschen wirken dass man wir essen
das ganze jetzt erstmal ganz häufig
braucht meine hilfe übrigen winter also
vielleicht schon gegessen das machen wir
schon dann sehen wir uns klar das müsste
jetzt hier so sanitäter nämlich auch so
einer liege raustragen heiter aber was
soll ich sagen insgesamt wieder ein
erfolg ja alles lecker wirklich
ausnahmslos total überrascht hat mich
das treffen dass das so frank iwer und
weich und alles drum und dran und so weg
nach tokio geschmeckt hat einfach die
sie rahmen waren sehr geil diese leichte
schärfe hat richtig dicken klops crunchy
leckerbissen konnte gelten die sein
können aber ansonsten wirklich getränk
supergut dazu gepasst insgesamt
durchdachter die dann erfolgt man kann
nichts falsch machen habe ich das gefühl
zumindest wenn man das so machen wie wir
es heute gemacht haben einfach keiner
sagen bring mal was worauf du lust hast
gefallen hat es gerne da ich bis auf und
abonniert bei dem wir die mio
[Musik]